so hi everyone thanks for tuning in to
my talk
my name is miraf and today i will share
with you ways i found in which network x
can be useful to us when we do
clustering analysis
but before that quick hello hi i'm miral
i'm a data scientist at salesforce i'm
from israel i live in tel aviv
i have a master's degree in
bioinformatics where my research focused
on
the microbiome
and i also did the side projects in
virology immunology and epidemiology but
it was before the covet so nothing
really interesting there
sometimes i write blog posts you can
find them on media and i can i will also
show a link to the blog after
and fun fact i do photography and i also
contribute to shutterstock and getting
so if you're curious you can google my
name and find the images i took
over there
and that's all about me
so the agenda for today is as follows
first of all we'll do a small graphs
recap so as promised in the talk
description there is no prior knowledge
needed even if you don't know what a
graph is we will have you covered but
really briefly then we will do a short
intro to network x which is a really
good package for analyzing graphs and
then i will show some examples of how
network x can assist us in clustering
analysis as promised
good so from the very beginning a graph
is a collection of nodes which are
basically dots in space
and edges which are lines connecting
them
and what is powerful about these data
structures is that it allows us to
represent both entities and the
relations between them
so just a few common examples of
things being represented with graphs we
have
the most
familiar example probably is social
networks we have event graphs where you
can represent for example airports like
flights airport flew from arrived at etc
we have networks of neurons
and we also have citation networks where
every paper is a node and if a paper
cited another paper then we will draw an
edge to it
and in that context i wanted to show you
a really useful tool i just thought of
it this morning that's why it's not in
the slides
so this is called connected papers does
anyone know it
you do cool
if you don't even call it
so you can put
a paper here and then build a graph
and then you get like the
you know the landscape of the paper you
looked for and it's really useful for
um
doing an like literature review so
pretty
quickly you get the preview of the paper
like the abstract and you can see how
central it is in the landscape of where
it is and you can see some that are
peripheral like this one only cited
another paper and hasn't been cited once
etc so it's really useful i highly
recommend using it and it's an israeli
development so i can be proud
of where i'm from
um
good um and in the context of clustering
we can use uh graphs to represent for
example entities belonging to a cluster
or
distances between clusters to see the
landscape of our data pretty easily so
those are just few examples
now two more things that make graphs
really hot is first that it's been
around for a long time
the first time a paper has been
published in the in the field of rough
theory was in 1735 which is pretty much
handing to us on a plate 300 years of
research in a really hot field and we
have tons of algorithms we can apply
right away on our data today to get
answers to really hot questions so for
example we can use for transportation
shortest path for younger over et cetera
and the second thing which i wrote one
for
just to test your concentration
it keeps advancing so
nowadays we have ml algorithms specific
for graphs for example link prediction
which allows us given a set of nodes and
edges that are already connected to
predict which edges will be connected in
the future so if anyone is still on
facebook
am i the only boomer still on facebook
good so you know the feature of people
you may know so one way to calculate
that is link prediction
um and another thing that exists today
is graph neural networks so you can do
um
you can study graphs in deep learning
manner using for example by geometric
which is a platform built upon
by dart and you can do deep learning on
graphs as well
so now that everyone in the room
convinced
that graphs are the thing and we should
be using those the next question we
should probably address is how and my
answer to that is network x which is my
go-to library when i want to work with
graphs so according to their
documentation it is one of the most
frequently used python packages to
create manipulate and mine graphs and
what does it provide so first thing it
does is it provides us several classes
to store
different types of graphs for examples
directed undirected all types it covers
a lot
it gives us a really simple conversion
of data from pandas data frame to graph
which i find super useful
it has
a really
um
big
set of visualization methods with lots
of features like you can
do several layouts of the graph you can
color edges you can color nodes you can
do sort of a heat map where your edge
color is darker the higher it is and
brighter the lower it is and many
options and you can find examples in the
gallery section
and also it gives us
plenty of useful methods to study graphs
for example um
from
basic characteristics of a node for
example the degree and between a
centrality like how a central it is to
um
advanced algorithm implemented for
example community detection page ranks
and many more
so i really recommend looking into that
and another really good feature i like
about network x is the gallery section
where you can find um
lots of code and notebooks with examples
of advanced things you can do such as
really complex and detailed
visualizations as well as how to apply
advanced algorithms on data sets
but how is this all relevant to
clustering you must be wondering so i
will tell you right away
so first thing we can do with the
network x that is user useful for
clustering is visualization
so
on my master's degree i had a problem i
did lots of clustering on the bacterial
data sets
and i always had a problem with
displaying my results like aesthetically
and in a way that conveys the idea
and they couldn't find a solution to it
back then
and then after i graduated i did a side
project um
where i took data set from the un about
female representation in parliaments
worldwide
and i had a table
with subcontinents and by subcontinents
you can see the results here it means
eastern europe
central asia central america south
america etc so i had a bunch of those
and i had for each one for each year
since the 90s until
2019
how many seats were taken by women in
their parliaments
so i had a table where each column was
here each row was a subcontinent and
each cell was how many
representations and then i had all those
patterns per subcontinent so i decided
to cluster those and see if i have
groups of patterns i can learn from and
like which subcontinents behave
the same
so i clustered those into five groups
and again i had the problem of how to
represent it so after digging really
deep in the results in google images of
clustering clustering results
visualization
i stumbled upon this visualization
done using a package i never heard of
before called network x and i really
liked it and that's how i learned about
this package
and it's visualization options so what i
did was i uh
represented my data
in a data frame
where
i had two columns one was subcontinent
and one was the cluster
and i converted this into a graph
where i got five components that were
connected and the cluster number was in
the center
and that's how i managed to visualize my
groups
uh of results
and it did the layout and all the now
you know
circles around and placing in the space
for me so i really recommend looking
into the visualization and i do want to
highlight that it doesn't even have to
be done using graphs you can just
convert your data to graph for the
visualization and then get back to what
you did so i found it really really
useful and i hope that so will you
now the second
way is that
let's say i have a data set of sentences
and that it's really big like really big
like 10 000 sentences
and i want to get an idea of what people
are talking about in this data set
so i'm running k-means and i'm not
exactly sure how many clusters i should
be like clustering to
but i don't want to divide too roughly
like i prefer to have many groups that
are very specific
instead of one group that contains lots
of you know things that are
fairly related
so i cluster my data set into 40
clusters
and then i start looking into the
results so i look at the first cluster
and i see the sentences i figured that
this is of certain topic and then i look
at the second cluster and i figure it's
of another topic and then after a few
blasters i start seeing that some topics
come up
several times
now there is some logic in the way they
were separated into groups but they all
belonged to one higher a topic
and
now i want
some tool to automate the process of
grouping together all those clusters
that have the same higher topic
so one way to solve this would be
hierarchical clustering but i already
have the results of k-means and i'm
pretty happy with them i just needed to
automate it for me
so what i suggest doing is as follows um
i will convert my data
into a graph where
each node is a center of a cluster
and each edge is the distance between a
pair of clusters
okay
good
um so as you can see on the left side
i have a graph that is fully connected
because each pair of centers has a
distance obviously and then i say um
actually i'm only interested in ones
that are really close to each other
because that's how my space will look
right if i'm looking for places with the
same topic so i
clear out all the edges that are above
some threshold and that's how i get the
second part of the graph and in this
graph you can see that i have again
independent components and i define
those as the groups with connected
topics
and then i can easily extract the list
of
clusters using networking
and i will show an example of the code
used for it
this
good so let's say i already trained a
k-means model and i named it in a very
original name i named it k-means model
so first thing i do i
i extract the centers using k-means
built-in function called a cluster
centers
then i calculate the distance between
each pair using scipy's a pdist
function which receives an array and the
method you like to calculate the
distance with
um
i chose cosine but it's very
it's not very important
it could be euclidean as well
then i turn it into a square form and
this is important because later on i
would want to turn this into a data
framework and convert the graph so what
it does it basically turns it into a
matrix with the distances between each
pair
and the size of the matrix is k on k
cool
now i turn this thing into a data frame
um
or i have two three columns
cluster one cluster due and the distance
between them
okay and don't forget to reset the index
always
then i name the colors the columns
cluster one cluster two and this
and then i start doing some
pre-processing
uh
that's all the part here so the first
thing i do is i remove all rows where
the distance is zero because these rows
include cluster distances from
themselves and with all due respect it's
not interesting to me
and the second thing i do is i subtract
all
i remove all the rows where the distance
is above some value now here i set it to
be 0.1 but it's really arbitrary and you
can play with different values and you
can also do it
automatically using for example a
z-score or
some percentile right
to
fetch the distance for you but for me it
worked with the 0.1
and the last thing i do i demand that in
all rows my cluster one number will be
higher than cluster two number
why is that because i don't want to have
duplicated rows right because each pair
will appear twice like in cluster one
one two and then two one and only one to
have it once
so that's how i drop all the things that
i don't care about and then
as i promised before this is how you
convert data from pandas
to graph
so what it receives is
the
data frame
the from and the two even if it's
undirected that's what it expects to
receive
and then what will happen is that the
extraction will happen
so this function extracts all connected
components in the form of a list
and
this part of the
list comprehension will iterate over
each component and put all the nodes
that belong to it in a list and then
eventually in s we will have
list of lists with the nodes belonging
to
each component
um and i really invite you to
try it out yourself i found it really
good and although it was a little
complicated and took a while to explain
it's really straightforward when you
once you understand you have the codes
on a plate so
you're welcome
good so what we did today was a really
quick refree app
a small network store
network extor
i showed you ways in which network x and
graphs in general can assist us
in clustering analysis and i will say
that there are other packages well you
can explore and other visualization
methods and stuff so you don't have to
stick with network gigs i was just
finding it convenient to show
the code which i use and we had loads of
fun at least me
any questions
i have two questions
one is
when working with sentences to class and
to grab them and create clusters how
important is that it's killing school
words
sorry i don't understand
i mean general terms which are done that
they think
i mean stop words
is it important to exclude them because
if you don't exclude then you'll get a
lot of artificial clusters
right
and second one is
where to stop when we shoot the number
fast
you mentioned you are doing some
optimization probably and
what kind of indicators we use
to say that this number of clusters
so i usually use the uh
elbow method you know when you cross
around
no network x is only for analyzing the
results i already have and everything
else is done using
i don't know
so
in this scope of the step of this talk i
only discuss ways to
um handle results already received using
clustering
um but for choosing a number of clusters
i usually use elbow and i sometimes just
run like randomly and see if it makes
sense
like roughly like if 40 didn't satisfy
then 60 like this kind of thing
and
regarding what you said about stop words
it depends on the embedding method
you're using so if you're using tfidf
etc that refers to the word itself then
it will probably
yield really noisy results if you don't
do the cleaning before but if you use
methods such as the s bart which is bird
for sentences then you don't need to do
all the pre-processing
in fact it's better to not do it because
it understands the context
of the words and it gives the embedding
according to the word in relation to the
entire sentence
so i hope it enters okay thanks and one
more question about uh
network about graphs the networking
package has some tools to do
graphs on any graph
like
the traditional
i think it allows you to use the only
types of graphs you like
i think you can
i mean if you you have a sentence this
is me
then
[Music]
you can convert it to words adjacent to
each other like word one
or two
this is and then is
me
and then ask you to
do a graph for you then
i hope you can see something and also
understand the hand right
then this will be connected
and if you want this to be connected as
well although it's not adjacent then you
should write a function that iterates
like this
right and then you will have
this
and it will have the trigram
as a connected component is this what
you meant
yes so we don't have built-in like
free ground
so basically what you drawn there it's
big girl right so you use bigger all the
time
this
i don't think they have a built-in
package for a like function for
conversion you would have to implement
it yourself but if i understand
correctly what you mean that you should
be breaking down the sentence according
to your requirements
like as i did here
maybe without fully understanding what
you intended but i tried um and then you
convert this from the gra from the data
graph data frames are in so you have a
sentence
you convert it to data frame and then
you convert it to graph
on your own and then you can do the
entire analysis visualization all the
fun things i showed you with networking
but network x will only work for
converting from data frame
and also other data types so if you dig
into the conversion functions you might
find something relevant to it and i will
also
say that this is open source package so
if you think it can be useful to
implement methods for nlp
as part of the package then you can do
it and that would be really appreciated
okay
thanks
thank you very much for a very
interesting speech
i wanted to ask if you if you have tried
some other packages other than networks
for example bankrupt they said that
it could bust in some ways
which one how are you
i know that to myself and i will come
back next year with the comparison
no i'm loyal to network x
anyone else want to ask
cool
glad to hear
so thanks a lot for your time
uh this is the link to my
blog post please visit
i
didn't publish in a while but i hope to
publish again soon and i would really
appreciate to hear your comments you can
hear about the work on a woman in
parliament
uh this is my linkedin please feel free
to connect i would be happy to approve
and they have friends in armenia and
also this is my man feel free to reach
out if you want to ask any questions
like how are you morals nowadays
great so thanks a lot